this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart
coors purestamps.com and expressvpn more
on that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com
uh please subscribe to the youtube
channel this community is continuing to
grow grow grow
and i can't thank you enough for that
for real it means a lot to me
uh the patreon as well the honeydew with
y'all we're doing over there
that uh community continues to grow and
the stories
i can't get over the [ __ ] you guys are
sending me in we have we have
a bunch recorded we have people sending
[ __ ] in that's
someone solved an 18 year old cold case
uh i found a human skull on a work site
can't wait to talk to you
there's so much [ __ ] going on out there
so subscribe to the patreon it's five
bucks a month if you sign up for your
year
you get over a month free and we put the
honeydew up a day early ad free at no
additional cost
all right you guys know i record here at
the santa monica music center i'm very
proud to tell you that
uh we just finished two episodes with
culver city high school kids okay so i
created a curriculum with lana
for uh culver city high school because i
really think podcasting
is replacing journalism all right that's
my opinion
we interviewed the mayor of culver city
and the chief of police of culver city
with this class of kids
uh and it went great so we're gonna keep
doing that i love giving back
it's outreach through the arts you guys
will be seeing me promote a lot of that
stuff
the honeydew podcast is where you go for
anything honeydew related all right
now that you know all that you guys know
we do over here we highlight the low
lights
i always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers and today
first time here on the honeydew so
[ __ ] excited
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
nikki glazer y'all welcome to the
honeydew nicki glass
so glad to be here i'm so surprised i
mean i feel like we've been
doing like podcasting since i i got here
because i feel comfortable like i was
just listening to you just then i was
just like
lo i love this medium and i don't know
about replacing journalism
that's a big thing like i think it's a
part of journalism it's a it's
taking up space and the journalism is a
thing that is well some journalism has
become
[ __ ] and that's what i mean
clickbait i mean clickbait so it's
replacing
like television news like cable news and
newspapers that have too big of a slant
like people are getting their
information
from podcasting now i hope people don't
look
to me for political knowledge or your
news or like what's going on in the
middle east
like [ __ ] with any of you so in my
podcast does not replace
is journalism in any way it replaces
maybe the today show segment
where you know the guy on the street
section has a real moment
uh well please before we get into
everything plug everything and anything
you want your shows your tour
all of it all right i'm on tour it's
coming up
it's looming uh from july until
uh like forever like i'm no i don't know
like until the winter but i'm going on
tour again
i'm so excited i am excited about it i'm
nervous about it because i'm putting a
lot of pressure on myself for it to be
great because
when people are spending this much money
to see you i feel like guilty i'm just
like agree
i have to give them something that's
like undeniably
yes good you're their weekend yeah
that's what they do
what did you do this weekend we went to
see nikki glazer how was it it was
either good or it wasn't good
the weight of that and i like i am not
doing the imposter syndrome thing of
like
they're wrong you know like they're
right respect that they enjoy you
you are good give them the best show you
can give have it
be fun have it be memorable um i'm like
i'm just gonna make it
uh i don't know i'm i get bored watching
someone just talk on mike for
an hour even if they're like the person
i love more than anything in the world
like
i i don't know that i have the stamina
right now like
i want to see something else so i'm
going to give people
other things like i want to incorporate
like pictures at like a slideshow and
this has been done before this isn't
like in stand-up but
i want to just venture out and start
having more fun i agree i don't know the
media yeah
i want to replace journalism that's what
i'm talking about it's why it's just
on the road journalists road journalism
um
you have a new show right now oh yeah
okay so i'm going on the road
i have a new podcast called the nikki
laser podcast it's a daily podcast it's
kind of like it's just me and my
roommate andrew cullen who's been on
your show
who his episode will come out after
years oh really it's not out yet oh yeah
because i would have heard about it oh
my god he would have been posting all
week it would have been like
he would have had a nervous energy in
the kitchen that morning where then i
would have been like what's going on
today
why are you biting your hand uh like we
both like he bites his family good
service and i pick on this thing on my
knee
and we always catch each other like
where we're like stop picking and
sometimes i'm like i
want to pick this there's a piece of
skin and i want to get it it has nothing
to do with the fact that he didn't text
me back
like but it so he was doing that but he
does it about
getting excited too when he gets excited
i'm just like what's going on the the
podcast came out how is it except
how are people liking it i'm getting a
lot of good feedback i'll do the whole
thing i care i'm happy for him but uh
yeah i uh i forgot where i was going
with that whole thing but
you were plugging your podcast oh yeah
podcast i'm so bad at plugging i gotcha
no the nikki glazer podcast i'm so proud
of it i do it daily monday through
thursday
you can jump in whenever you want you
don't want to like go back to old
episodes like understand it we'll catch
you up on inside jokes
it's every day you can drop in and out
whenever you want it's like a morning
show
that you happen to catch sometimes on
the way to work and you're like i kind
of know these people
and i genuinely feel like they're the
people i that listen to
the cast are like my friends like they
are they love
it's almost delusional on my part i've
never felt that way with fans before
even with stand-up fans like
but that's because there's so real
connection yes it's like it
i and i'm saying stuff that i'm like
you're living your life i don't
let my parents i don't want my parents
to listen to it i don't want my closest
friends to listen to it i don't want my
boyfriend like if i ever get one i don't
want him like tuning in i want to be
able to process my feelings in a way
that won't
like it might breaches their privacy a
little bit but
in a way that we've agreed upon so
entering into today with you and wanting
to talk about stuff that like
is really emotional to me some of these
things i'm about to share like i've
learned
just the risky way of talking about them
and then and then they hear the podcast
eventually
and then they are like hey i heard that
and then they're either cool or not and
i've been lucky that they've all been
cool because i've been gambling not all
of them my mom did not appreciate my
jokes
about her never discouraged me from it
but didn't appreciate my jokes about
um her drinking when i first started but
i kind of was like
well i'm mad about it and so stop
drinking and i'll stop doing them
you know like that kind of thing like
yeah so but now i have
a lot more compassion for someone who
might
rely on something to get through their
life and doesn't want to give it up
because it's too scary i mean i do that
with work i do that with
my daughter will talk about how her dad
smoked weed for sure yeah i mean it's a
thing she'll
she'll have to be like and then he was
checked out like you like when she wants
to create that narrative she'll be like
he was so dialed in it was annoying i
know
well that's funny that's so funny
sometimes i wish he was a drinker
yeah because when you smoke weed you get
yeah i'm telling you i want to do
everything
too we did this whole studio and
everything i would smoke enjoy i'm like
let's go
paint let's bubba you know i like that i
like what marijuana does for me i have
to accept that that's the way it
manifests in me as well like it's really
suits my add it gives me like a boost of
energy
and but some people that struggle with
pot addiction which i see all the time
in the subreddit leaves like i'm always
just lurking
about when i want to stop doing it
because i've i've been able to
like kick uh what did i say the other
night and you were like you were
laughing so hard
at the comedy store oh was that you no
we were at supernova
someone who i always get mixed up with
you had said to me
literally i get you guys all kind of
look the same to me
sometimes like you because i i will have
bursts of hanging out with you on
podcasts
like in the mid uh
like 2009. that was a long time ago and
then since then i'm not like keeping up
with clips like
the algorithm feeds you so sometimes i
get you
confused with other people if you were
black this would be way more
uncomfortable
do you know what i mean but that happens
too to me all the time
it happens with everyone like i am bad
with faces
uh people i care about like i don't i'm
not claiming to have that bad pit thing
i'm already looking for faces gives them
an excuse to be able to face but i don't
remember your name so it doesn't really
help me oh
faces for me are the thing where i'm
like i don't know so you'll know a name
but you couldn't put the face to the
name you're like i know that name i know
that name
probably be better at remembering names
than faces
it's not a social butterfly anyway so
it's no no ding on you i just don't
[ __ ]
i'm not out yeah but that's you know i
did spend some time with you the other
night and
i should have not confused you with the
precise of the comments so i forget what
i said but i said i
i was talking about um quitting uh pot
or
uh alcohol and like als and
a couple other things in my life like
i've put like i've sober from these
things that like
lead to me being like not being able to
work as efficiently really it's all
about like if this affects my career
then it's gone
it can do everything else in my life
like no service to any other facet of my
life
and i will allow it to exist but the
second it starts [ __ ] with my work
i gotta address it so um yeah that
allows me to
have certain addictions for a longer
time that are harder to let go but
i'm addicted to caffeine i'm addicted
caffeine would be the hardest one
you think i'm also following that
subreddit decaf they talk about it
i've read this is the thing i've read
the withdrawal say one thing
and by the way on leaves the subreddit
for quitting smoking pot
people need to quit it and they're that
it makes them lazy and they're addicted
how wouldn't that be awful that would be
look if you're gonna smoke weed and just
lay on your couch it's like angry drunks
you're like what
if you're a nice drunk that's why
marijuana doesn't work for you i always
said about my mom i
she's a nice drunk so we were always
like you're kind of the best when you're
this way so it's like we didn't want her
to get her
help for a while we're like do it more
like so when people are nice trunks you
sometimes can encourage them can i just
say something to you
yeah that's positive yeah quit the
subreddits
don't worry about that no i love
subreddits don't worry about that so
many stories yeah though you've got to
say
there's honeydews all over reddit
because people feel safe and they're
like really smart funny people
in there telling their stories of their
life and just
you learn a lot about humans on reddit i
love it and then
it's more real than anything but i'm
saying if you want to quit something no
well i was
that's the best place i'm serious people
that want a quick d read
on decaf just starts following it i'm
serious these are helpful communities
because i find that before i'm ready to
quit something i
i just start like kind of like scoping
out like
what if i no not just reddit but just
asking people about what it's like to
not drink and like huh
i'm like collecting information just
poking around like not ready to do it
yet
i got this book that helped me quit
drink or smoking
alan carr easy way like you were smoking
yeah all you were oh i loved it you did
it's disgusting and i loved it
um i still love that when someone
strikes a match
and hits the lights of cigarettes yeah
it's cool that initial smell that first
one before there's a pool i think it's
probably the
it smells so good and then after that as
soon as you pull it in and all the
points i know i'm getting a headache
just thinking about it like
thankfully they give me headaches now
smell of smoke and so
that's so much pain that i would never
that i associated with that i didn't i
i wouldn't struggle with it but this
book when i still craved cigarettes and
wasn't getting headaches from them when
i was younger
um it immediately helped me drop secrets
immediately and i was like what the [ __ ]
was that i just read a book and now i
don't want to smoke cigarettes at the
end it goes smoke
you can read it you can smoke the whole
time you read it he encourages you too
and all you do is get unbrainwashed by
what you've been brainwashed to think
about your addiction to cigarettes
cigarettes because what you think your
addiction is you've been lied to it's
not that it's not as bad
as you've been told is that right
tobacco companies their propaganda
they've spread the message quitting
smoking is hard because it makes you go
i gotta keep doing it it's hard like i'm
like it makes it so
you can fall back and keep doing it so
it seems counterintuitive that they
would
spread the message that cigarettes are
extremely addictive
but it actually works to their advantage
in the end because people won't quit but
it's actually a lot easier than
one would think caffeine not as
easy and also and then i also read the
drinking book so when i was flirting
with quitting drinking i got that guy's
book
for drinking and i just put it on my
shelf because i was like i'm circling
the drain here on this
literally like in the shower like i
like the the worst it was just the
hangover being drunk was awesome i never
really did anything that reckless or
you aren't humiliating i mean i was
no never violent sometimes i would be
angry sometimes i my friends would tell
me about blackout
anger episodes but very very few very
few and especially towards the end when
i was able to control
that or thought i had some control
didn't at all
but i was having sex on it
like i it was only way i could have sex
why why the
what do you mean the cop to get the
confidence to do it yeah no work up the
nerves to do what i really like
wanted to do or like to be like to get
out of my head
it was just like an instant like you
know liquid courage but ultimately what
i learned in reading this book is that
it's not liquid courage it's just making
you dumber
like that's all it does it's like a
retardant like it just
which isn't the right word but you know
what i'm saying like it just makes sense
it is the right word actually yeah i
think [ __ ] is something that puts
out the flames
well that's flame retardant fire
retardant yeah so it's like i don't know
i think you can use it across the board
i don't know if you that word's making a
comeback the you know the word
that we're circling the dream come back
i think so people are like starting to
test the waters with that word again
and i i i'm not it's not like it's
throwing it out in casual conversations
they're working it in back you know just
in back rooms
amongst like comedians who get it and
aren't going to snitch yes
yeah or record and send them but i've
heard the r word a couple of times
it's not like the same reaction if
someone dropped the n word back there
it would be an issue of course uh after
we all chimed in
um no no it would be but i'm so bad you
coughed at that moment because i needed
your laugh
to confirm but there was a moment where
like people are just
the sds after that dude it like
it you left me hanging on that one and
uh
people no it's uh
that word is making a comeback i've
heard it and i'm like okay i'm letting
cause that word
if it offends people i i don't
you know what if it offends people it
makes them feel bad i can think of a
different word
that's my answer actually it's not that
important i have an old joke with it i
just don't do it
oh i definitely said it before on stage
i burned it on the tonight show
three months ago when you could say it
on there i said did a rape joke
on the tonight show on first tonight
show jay leno
i did a joke you were allowed to say the
rape word the word rape
i got this this is wild talk about a
[ __ ] highlight of my life
i i am a am i blackout drunk
like like not taking care of myself
eating
binging at night probably like bulimic
at this point like i went from anorexia
i started anorexia and was like
never gonna go the other way always
going to be good and skinny
then you i slingshotted the other way
not too bad but i was like
puking and drinking and like eating and
i was just
dis bloated like so gross it was january
of 2009 i had been approved to do the
tonight show
in like to late 2007
and so i went a whole year maybe fall
2007. i went a year or
and more with being told i was gonna do
this right right away when they were
like the sets approved oh said i
had run by them like several times
following it
um hold on no it's fine it's fine it's
fine we can get a paper towel no
you stay there no you don't need a paper
i got a set approved like went through
like like so many times with these guys
uh bob and ross from the tonight show
who originally saw me on last coming
standing when they were the judges when
i was in chicago when i auditioned for
the last comic standing my senior year
of college
i drove with a bunch of comedians from
kansas city to chicago to audition i
stood out in line waited in the cold
auditioned didn't deserve to make it
through knew i didn't was prepared to be
the dap
fan if i got through all i wanted was to
not be made fun of
and go on a trip with 10 comedians from
kansas city in a van it was so fun
get there i got through the first round
because i
they were like bob and ross the boogers
for the tonight show who come to play
later
they i'm i'm in kansas city doing stand
up for
i don't know this is my senior year of i
should just go back and tell my whole
story
anorexic in high school uh
senior year i want to talk about why
what what were you
i i i caught anorexia um
because you caught it yeah is that what
you say
well do do you get well i guess you
could say get cancer and catch cancer
but like it can't it's like it's not
something
that it was my fault mental illness
i'm already like starting to cry i have
a lot of like anger about people who
think you're choosing not to eat because
it's a thing that like people don't
understand it they think like
you want to be skinny you're just you're
it's vanity there's nothing
vain about it at all so this is not a
body dysmorphia
or i mean it definitely was that it
started as like
what it started as was my senior year
these are the events that led to it and
we can go back and investigate yeah will
you tell me because these are things
that interest me like what
i know the vogues and the videos and all
the [ __ ] and photoshop that that
peppers women with like you have you can
look this beautiful you should
which is all unrealistic and we all know
that but we still go for it you were
telling me about these filters that i
even [ __ ] know about for instagram
and stuff
yeah so where does it come from like
where does it get where does that seed
get planted for you
well you are an intelligent woman who
looks around you and sees that
the women who get heard and get to do
things and get to be the spotlight and
get to be loved
are the ones who are prettiest and
and most [ __ ] to men you put that
two and two together you look at
yourself you realize
i don't first of all i don't have it in
me to [ __ ] men like i don't want it like
even i don't want to put that out there
because i'm so scared of
male sexual energy for what i don't even
know why but what age is this that
you're already going with oh when i
realized
yeah at what age were you already like
oh got it
i realized i was like not cute i think
um
oh god it came in such like different
stages but probably when my sister
started getting attention for being cute
okay so that's when i first have an
older sister
younger and so i started seeing like oh
that's what pretty girls get to hear all
the time is like how beautiful they are
and literally
multiple times and i felt like unseen
because it would just be
my parents wouldn't acknowledge it but
like women would stop my mom and tell my
sister that she was like beautiful and
then not say anything to me and like
it was constantly a topic because she
was so beautiful it was like notable
if you've ever been around people who
are like models or you know
actresses like i was friends with
jennifer lawrence for a little bit and
being around her
you just are like you scared i like i
could i just feel like you're
so pretty like do you know that like not
trying to but i'm just like dude
i can't like deal with what how this
could
exist on a face like my dancing with the
stars partner was like that he's the
hottest guy
i've literally ever looked seen in the
flesh
and i i understand having to stop and go
you're
so hot like i would be with him because
people always were like nikki
surely you're exaggerating like i told
andrew about him i'm like he's the
hottest guy i've ever seen in person
like i'm not lying when i say that
and i'm touching him five hours a day i
mean yeah for a month every day
and just sexy dances like this how hard
is that
well for a woman who suffers with
opening herself up to
male or female like any um sexual
like uh physical intimacy like when i do
open myself up to it
i'm a [ __ ] i'm the filthiest
like most depraved [ __ ] like i'm capable
of such
wild profane acts
and i'm not saying that to be like
sexual like oh my god
no one stands a chance like i am so
closed off
my dungeon of which i'd like to be tied
up in
is the walls are built so uh
i i it's hard for me to let i let people
in that
uh don't wanna are like that can't come
in
and that's what i go after let's take a
quick break and tell you about our first
sponsor
upstart if you have multiple credit
cards you know that tracking multiple
balances due dates and website logins
can be stressful upstart
makes things simple with one monthly
payment in one place
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online so whether it's paying off
credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment and i know a lot of you
have that's why they keep coming back
you guys are using it you've messaged me
tell me how much
better it's made your life i wish i had
something like this when i was younger i
know i paid
thousands and thousands of dollars in
interest i shouldn't have
upstart find smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess
more than just your credit score with a
five minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans from
one thousand to fifty thousand dollars
you can get approved the same day and
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day so if debt
is taking over your life it's time to
get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com honeydew
that's
upstart.com honeydew don't forget to use
my url
to let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew
my favorite beer is back coors pure do
you ever feel the pressure to keep up a
healthy life like you try to get a
workout daily you eat healthy all the
time
you keep up with the wellness trends and
you feel like you're trying
so hard all the time and sometimes the
simple act of using a standing desk or
getting a quick run in
is enough to celebrate those are the
days you grab a coors pure an organic
beer that is
all about celebrating the winds of
everyday life it's organic
but it's chill about it look it's my
favorite beer i take it everywhere i've
had three crab feeds already this summer
i take
coors pure to everyone on my go to
everybody already loves coors light i'm
like if you love coors you're gonna love
coors pure
it's a refreshingly simple beer with
organic barley
organic hops and water that's it at 92
calories and zero
sugar it's the perfect beer to celebrate
the winds
of everyday life coors pure is the
perfect beer to celebrate the winds of
everyday life so when you want to enjoy
a beer without the guilt reach for coors
pure
it's organic but chill about it go to
coorspure.com
to see where you can find coors pure i
found mine here in california and target
all right
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany
georgia so going back to
god i mean like where do we start so
we're wanting to be beautiful but wait
let me ask you a question now
game is rigged hold on rigged against
girls who aren't cute
she's getting opportunities and you're
like whoa and i'm like what am i gonna
do so i became obsessed with jennifer
aniston in sixth grade that was the
first time i was like
okay here's someone with my same kind of
coloring like i could see myself in her
and i'm like i want to be that she's
cute she's not overly sexy she's not
this like
it's just like she's just like oh she's
just like oh she's like kind of
fun and like oh and i just like loved
her vibe i was like i'm gonna be here so
i
was i read i've got all the friends
books i was in sixth grade
i realized she was 25 when she got the
role and i was like okay that's my
course of life i'm just gonna be
i'm gonna be on a show like this with a
bunch of my
other white people and and when i'm 25
which
someone pointed out recently that that
would oh bill maher on a show last week
pointed out that like friends
now would not exist and that's like why
that reunion was kind of like what's
going on like where's
any um you know that review was
frightening i couldn't watch it i
couldn't even i didn't there were some
faces i couldn't look at
just i was sewing just seeing pictures
of it i was just like
i want everyone to look like happier
maybe they are happy and their faces
can't show it but
and i don't blame anyone for getting
work done i've had work done
are you really laughing that was that's
so nice
it's just listen cause i agree listen i
agree
i get my botox i can't tell you this is
before
if we were talking right now look at my
forehead look look how good i could i'm
just gonna do a xylophone
i can wash my intimates on it in the
sink at
a [ __ ] red roof yeah back
and then the road days early road days i
would go before bob and tom i'd want to
smell i
had only forgotten i forgot no underwear
oh my god
that is so one time i literally only
brought one pair of underwear and i
talk about being a [ __ ] i was just like
having filthy sex for the first time in
my life with like
the first boyfriend i got when i was 24.
ugh
right before the tonight show while i
did the tonight show he was in my life
did it didn't say anything after it
aired didn't congratulate me bad person
come on i know just just an addict
honestly just a
sweet sweet addict but we used to have
filthy sex
but one time one time i was leaving uh
i had to go somewhere i needed to wear
underwear and i like you know i just
like
like they were pretty sweat and i know i
i hate talking about sex as much because
people always comment
the though she talks about it's just
like really it's just funny and i don't
give a [ __ ] so just don't comment that i
just can't anymore
oh she talks about sex i'm not i've had
sex in two
years no yes years
yes two years i don't lie june 3rd i
think 2019. why
um i would like to say covet but that
only explains a year ago
only half of it so
things were no because i decided that i
don't have sex outside of uh
like i don't want to have sex until i
love someone because it just it
put i read the so wait i'm gonna stop
you right do you research on it
okay you won't don't have sex do you
love someone but does that mean that you
what if you're dating a guy for six
months you really like this dude but
you're not in love yet do you [ __ ] then
what are you doing for six months i know
i'm gonna know
listen i'm a little bit pete davidson
ariana grande love addict like i love
i love falling in love it happens fast i
believe that i can extend that honeymoon
period to
as much as possible because i've done
the research about like
how to keep like that alive because
it's impossible to keep it the same as
it is when you first start meeting and
[ __ ]
you can't i'm never gonna do that but
there are books that i've read
and science behind those books that
supports that you can keep your
relationship
really hot forever if you like just
follow some simple things that actually
already fit into my like
what book is that that's the book i want
i don't give a [ __ ]
on that you're gonna [ __ ] hate this
book am i yeah kind of
you're good no it's about manipulating
us no no no no no it's not it's not
then what is it it's the whole premise
of the book is
that everyone has to stop coming oh yeah
no pass on that is that tran is it uh
listen to me
this isn't about you don't get to be
about to come
which let's talk about it when you are
about to come that's better than coming
honestly that's the anticipation i know
i know the sweet
it's the sweet release but if you never
really release
that and you can in certain ways like
listen i understand you need to like get
it out
but i think what she says is that you
try to limit your master or like your
release
but you does include masturbation
but not like every day the fact that
we're doing this like
every day like we that's what i look
like when all the machinery i have
dude i literally my masturbation routine
is so
funny i mean i i really am reluctant to
talk about sex so much even though it's
my favorite subject
because pinned as this but it's so
interesting and i think it
empowers more women to be like i have a
really satisfying sex life by myself
like i that's what i was about to say or
is that why maybe you're not
looking for someone because you're
satisfied in the bedroom by yourself no
i was recently in a sexual like
really hot hot thing for a brief amount
of time
and it was that's where i got my release
was in that
and i gotta say two weeks into it like
there was one time where we couldn't
meet up and i was like i gotta go check
on my girls
i was like excited to go visit my girls
like and that's not me talking about my
body parts like my
my ladies in the dungeons i gotta go
refill their water bowls and check in on
them because they've been in those
dungeons like
i my porn stuff is really like kinky and
gone down some really weird cellar
corridors
stockades and [ __ ] yeah i mean like i i
literally i want to produce my own porn
because i'm specific about what i like
you're home for you do i would like for
yourself because my needs aren't being
met
and i am subscribed to three different
porn sites
and i search pornhub and spank bang
and i don't even know the house is good
hit bdsm.com that one's good but there's
pop the pop-ups [ __ ] you
oh uh yeah i i pay for my porn i feel
better about it because the things i
watch
these ladies can't be having that good
of a time they should get paid for what
they're doing yeah and guess what
when i i'm not saying that they're being
abused well some of them are but that's
in the con
that's in the deal that they worked out
before yeah no they they agree to it on
camera
with like you know holding a newspaper
i'm not a victim and they've checked
with them at the end to prove that they
survive
send me a link what you're [ __ ] into
over there i want to check it out yeah
literally go to kink.com and see what
they have i'm into almost everything
they have
but my needs are for me to make the
perfect
thing for myself um i
like i feel like that's why i like only
fans i'm like oh maybe i could just pay
someone that i think is hot or like
resembles me directly
to [ __ ] this other porn star and like
just tell them like hey can you
recreate this can you play out this
scenario and they're like believable
actors
and will you mic the man i don't want to
hear the woman i'll ins
like i want to hear her but like some
girls come in a different way i do
i don't think they're faking it but it's
like just different than the way i would
do it so it's like
gets i'm just like i am too much of you
so you should all for an audio
woman only man only or both or yeah
full give them audio options yeah yeah
but men need to be mic'd and i know that
they're not because men are like there's
too many stand-up
comedians being like i don't want to
hear the man's coming
in my porn and now all porn companies
are like we can't have the men
making any noise they shan't make a
peach but i want guys being like
i want to hear good girl more on porn i
want girls to be
tested and push their limits without you
being mean to them amen
how about you how about you nicely call
us a dirty [ __ ] who's not good for
anything except having your holes filled
how are you can you not [ __ ] saying
everything
i i mean this is can you not can you not
just
because literally you never get that i'm
not even like
like i'm not trying to be funny
literally there's no porn
where i feel like the guy that is like
being the
dominant one or t tying girls up there's
always like a little bit of aggression
like a an issue they're working out with
like their sisters thanksgiving plant
like
something's coming into it where you're
like there's like anger
yeah there's just something looming with
a woman that's a woman's messy
investigation
she's asking like she doesn't want the
kids to like be around you because you
work in the porn industry or there's
something like you
and so that day he just gives that girl
cheyenne
from [ __ ] cheyenne uh lips or
whatever
two piece two pieces yeah absolutely two
p's
and then you look into cheyenne lips
there's some girls dude this is the just
this is all stuff that's gonna end up in
my special so i'm honestly i'm not doing
material this is just stuff i like to
talk about
but these are all things that i've like
been thinking about recently when i'm
approaching going back to stand up
because
i have to analyze i've opened my eye if
i open my eyes to the
the bad stuff that happens to have the
videos that i enjoy made
to women that are like it seems like
maybe it's all legal but it's like a
little shady and i understand being a
woman that
finds yourself in a situation for work
and you end up doing something
extra that you don't want to do like it
sounds like you're describing
entertainment and
comedy also asking me to like make a
story to promote this on top of it i'll
be like
i didn't think this was part of the deal
but i'll do it i'm not gonna ask no i'm
just kidding no of course i'll do it but
i was just trying to make it like but
yeah there's always like a thing that
you do and you go i don't wanna [ __ ]
do this but i'm gonna do it because it's
easier than
when a guy grabs my ass when we're doing
a meet and greet
it's easier for me to just let him do it
and be done with the picture
than it is for me to be like get your
hand off my [ __ ] ass and making a
whole scene for people
walking his wife is there he'll deny it
well you know like i run the scenario in
my head where you accuse someone doing
something they'll just deny it
they'll just know it wasn't and then
it's your word against theirs then i
start going
maybe he didn't maybe like and who would
even want to grab my ass i have such a
flat ass like
i'll start lying to myself i literally
felt guilty sometimes when guys have
gone no i didn't i would never grab your
ass i'm like i'll never
choose anyone off anything again because
you might say that you didn't and you
wouldn't like that's my biggest fear is
like
you think i wanted you it like that's i
have this like
fear of boys and just of people thinking
i'm like ugly and like
unfuckable and like a dork because not
because i want to [ __ ] guys but because
i want
to feel value from men for the thing
that makes them
weak and give me some of their power
like that's essentially
why i want to be hot is not because i
want men to want to stick their dicks in
me yes that is great and i hope that the
person i end up with is
so sexually attracted to me but i don't
want that's not my desires to have
men like actually actively trying to
[ __ ] me it's like that's
not but i don't stop that though also i
want them to want to [ __ ] me so that
they'll give me some of their money
and their opportunities and that's
there's nothing and
i'm saying this subconsciously like i i
want to be perceived as hot
not because because it will make me get
more money to protect my family and
those i
love like it leads as opposed to being
like and the thing is it doesn't take
much to be hot you know what hotness is
in the long run being happy with
yourself and being confident with
yourself so
whether that confidence is like you get
that happy feeling
when you're when you're happy you're hot
it doesn't matter what you look like it
truly like it [ __ ] with people's minds
when you're
because you like look like [ __ ] and
they're just like i remember great
amy schumer one time went into a radio
station
when she was looking like [ __ ] before
she was famous and she uh
it's one of my favorite sorts she's just
like looks as gross as she could ever
look on the road in the morning when
you're just like
half awake she's doing this and she's
not like not even into it she's not
being like
she's actually she's always hilarious so
you know she's being funny but she just
looks like [ __ ] right
and she says that she senses like the
co-host in the corner just kind of like
like staring at her like kind of taking
her in and just being like kind of
puzzled and just like
just and she can just sense it so when
they go to break she was like hi
what's going on like what's and he just
goes
are you hot and it's
all because she was funny confident
and that's what's so great about that i
feel pretty movie is because when this
girl who
is the same girl suddenly has bumps her
head and thinks she's hot
just being happy with yourself and being
like this but the thing is
what you do learn is that that being hot
does not bring you happiness the hottest
i've been or when i
thought i was like oh i achieved it yeah
i wanted it like i'm the hottest that
like when i thought i'm peeking
i'm not happy i'm crying on the ground
having a spray tan drip off of me
and i feel too skinny because whenever
you look like
for me skinny equals hot because it's
like you look like a [ __ ] supermodel
and i'm like
you know when you're really that like
you just resemble what supermodels look
like so you think it's hot but skinny
for me
for you it is are you attracted to
skinny right but are you attracted to
skinny
for men yeah what are you attracted to
honestly i learned
recently i fell in love recently with a
person that i would have never
picked for myself to like but it was
instant
like attraction i couldn't like i wasn't
like it took a second to be like oh i
would want to [ __ ] this guy
and like you know i would want to make
out with this guy oh you can see that
you know
it takes me a really long time to get
there with anyone i really like
if they're super duper hot it doesn't
take as long but i felt something right
away and i ended up thinking this person
was like
the hottest thing ever and not like in a
way that i realized
that uh i because of someone that was so
outside of my type and i found him sexy
because not because
i just found his body sexy because i
loved him like i understood that love of
like
i don't i would never care what you
looked like ever
like i just like your spirit like that i
was like oh my god because i
haven't felt that kind of level before
you love the for who they are yeah and i
realized that i could look like anything
and that person would be okay with it
like i felt that background and also you
could look the hottest you've ever
[ __ ] felt and there's gonna be other
people out there that you know does
nothing for me i know
it's not you can't mainly when you're
trying to look hot you're tr it's like
you're trying to appeal to women
uh you know men like women you don't
have to do [ __ ] for us
no listen instagram hotness and all the
tricks behind it and all the effort
going into being hot it takes so much
time for being hot
i'm going on bill maher tomorrow and i
gave my st
i have stylist because i just it's such
a stressful thing figuring out what to
wear
and i like looking good and like looking
stylish and i have no confidence
we were outside and that lady walked by
and said i love your dress oh my god and
what did i think she said
you need to de-stress yeah like what
that's what i needed i needed to hear
that so that was nice and you're like oh
you said i wouldn't have said anything
better i would have been like [ __ ] you
like i would have literally let her and
then you go that was nice and i go
oh my god she said my dress that's so
nice and i got this dress at like a
really shitty secondhand store because
i'm trying not to contribute to like
new i don't like new clothes anymore i
like to like find stuff and like just
make it work but i don't i'm not good at
fashion so i outsource it
and my stylist what was it where was i
going you were talking about how
what a pain in the ass it is the little
yeah my stylist well they they make it
fun i do a fitting like yesterday i had
a fitting that was like an
hour and 15 minutes long which is trying
on clothes and looking at your naked
butt being naked from someone else i'm
very comfortable with it at this point
my
these girls have been working with
forever but they're like high-end
fashion like
they dress like models and pop stars and
like
do like vogue shoots and stuff like
they're they're legit and i only know
them because i'm
one of them uh worked on an mtv show but
she just went super like
very very style style but i like being
around her so i've left them
i've had them dress me and i trust them
but sometimes it's like
really fashion-forward stuff which i'm
like why not like why do i have to feel
guilty
about like for instance i went to the
iheartradio awards recently a high of my
life
for sure i got invited to do it i was
hosting or i was um
presenting best new artist like the
whole category
and um i got asked because the guy that
was directing it
had like seen me at the mtv awards and
was like that was good
i'm putting together this thing do you
want to do it and i knew him he was joel
gallon he also produced uh
yeah with joel yeah do you know that he
was the director for the prince
uh hall of fame yeah i saw him post that
yeah
he was there live for that you've seen
that tom petty i watched that thing
yeah it's crazy a semester um
i'm still going by school lingo because
you know i'm still going to school in my
dreams
i'm still in college in my dreams
running late for the final
i finally have that's finally stopped
for me that's really good that means
that you don't want to
have dead like you're not coming up on
deadlines that you dread and you're
pushing things off
i think that's what it is for me because
i'm like you didn't study you never went
to class
you didn't prepare you're not prepared
and now you have to face it what are you
gonna do
i would walk into um english and i'm
like well you're using protractors like
how much did i miss
you know all right let me refocus this i
want to refocus i'm all over the place
no
let's go back to because we talked about
relationships and
all of your struggles with hotness and
you talked about you wanted to talk
about your first boyfriend
which leads to an unfortunate event for
a friend oh my god how did you track
that that was so good
thanks i might be kidding these were
soaked
and i wanted to go do it
wait that's what the story no like that
not now i know but actually i'm no no
they're not they're i'm
good right now i did get horny earlier
this is so funny this happens to women
i got horny earlier in the day yesterday
and i guess i've just been so dehydrated
because i'm
usually in the midwest just gulping down
waters all the time i guess i don't ever
drink water but out here you feel it
i didn't go to pee from the time it was
horny until
like eight hours later jesus i mean it
was a long and
that's not a good time i know it's it's
i know and i had no desire to i finally
go pee
and like it's like 11 o'clock and i'm
like finally back from my set and i'm
like wow
i was like oh my god what the [ __ ] who
was i around tonight
i couldn't i could i was like who did i
see tonight that turned me on
and it was no one it was from eight
hours before i was like oh my god
yeah it was just like a uh yeah and
sometimes you just forget you're like
whoa what did i do earlier that made me
turn on
but that but uh so my panties were
soaked i was blow drying them i was
probably hung over my boyfriend was
probably just like smoking in the hotel
room just being
like gross and grumpy and not grumpy but
just like
just spectrum-y i don't know like
alcoholic spectrum brilliant
very smart genius levels i've never
heard
anybody call somebody spectrum listen
there's parts of the spectrum
that there are there's a lot of me i
feel like i'm all
i'm i got some little some things
everybody i feel like everybody if you
really dialed into every person like you
ate a lot of sweet love
when i was happy she also smoked through
the whole thing
um but i uh was blow drying them to dry
them so i could go
perform and not have like soaked
underwear yeah but like
a hot blow dryer to some funky like
wet old underwear it stunk up there it
was like
so it smelled like [ __ ] so much like it
was like
infused like it was a bonfire
it was just it was a good [ __ ] scent
but you don't want it that strong
matter yeah even perfume smells like you
oh my god this is humiliating
meanwhile he like did not care i mean
like
but sex is disgusting everything that
goes with it that's what i love about it
it's the first time i've ever go back to
your first boyfriend
ever we were gonna talk about him that's
how old you were when it was your first
serious boyfriend no high school
boyfriend okay
all right so i that was a little later
than i thought i thought maybe you dated
in high school or something
no boys liked me but i was scared of
boys
and so we were virgin also at 24 21 i
lost my virginity
but he wasn't a boyfriend no he had a
girlfriend it's a
that's a fun uh pattern in my life is
going after men who are different
kinds of unavailable whether they're in
a thing
and that's not going that well and
like that whole [ __ ] um and like i
really i'm on my way out like let's
start hooking up like
uh she's it's a done deal like i'm
pretty much single
even though we live together and ever
live together
i've been there yeah and ever listen
i love this whole idea that like women i
i was always wanted to distance myself
from
the idea that i would be a woman who
would
hook up with a guy who had a girlfriend
like i or with a wife
like i i got fingered by a guy that had
a wife one time but only because i knew
i got confirmation that he did it a lot
and that she like was cool with it but i
was also very young so i don't assume
that
they're divorced now so it does it's not
like my fingers
say that he fingered women a lot like
one of my friends was like no he hooks
up on the road like he's like he's a
scoundrel like
you and i didn't do anything to his
penis i didn't even like acknowledge it
so i feel like accepting a fingering is
not me like
going like he's choosing to do this i'm
just laying it out there
and it takes away account uh
accountability but i do have
accountability and the
i feel shame about being like i don't
like she's gonna be heard in this no
matter what but the thing is
so i've always wanted to just distance
myself from
the stories of my past where it was uh
dating a guy or hooking up with a guy
who had a girlfriend
but the truth and the thing is i went
many years without doing that and i was
like yes i'm finally over it like i
don't
do that anymore because that's just like
a one-way road to hurt and
hurt and something hurting someone else
and it's just like don't
and i wasn't even attracted to people
like i would just be it wouldn't occur
to me
um and but then i would try to find then
i just realized i was going after
men that were unavailable in other ways
like yeah sure they were single but they
were like
incapable of loving me like literally
would never say i love you and had
made up their mind that that's not
something they're ever going to tell
someone in life like they had these
things up that were like he
he can't be everything so it's so how
it's shameful to say but i yeah and i i
i've
i have uh not been uh
i have not stopped a romantic
relationship if i
girlfriends are just like i'm sorry
you're just a girlfriend if when i'm a
girlfriend i'm gonna have this
when i'm a wife i'm gonna have the same
[ __ ] rules listen i don't have a
problem with
my i'm kind of kinky and i'm into
hearing about
the person that i'm in love with in a
safe loving relationship i think i am
into like hot husbands like like hot
wife you know like oh my wife like [ __ ]
guys and it's kind of hot to me to watch
guys want to [ __ ] my wife i like when a
guy is [ __ ] like i like when my guy
like
girls want him and know that he's like
in a relationship and they can't have
him even though they'll trick themselves
into thinking they might be able to but
he's honest with them about him
i don't mind if my boyfriend or husband
would get a [ __ ] i don't want to hear
about it until
right before we're gonna [ __ ] and then i
want to hear all about it or
when i want to like we have an open
communication you're gonna be upset
about it after you
no no no i cause i don't believe
if that person that they hook up with
first of all i've never heard of a guy
getting a random [ __ ] on the road
this is a circumstance when it's like
you're in another city or a bachelor
party or whatever
if you need a girl to bar she wants to
suck your dick
yeah what i've never heard of a guy
getting a [ __ ] and
from some random girl in the road that's
like a drunken thing that like they're
both like partying and then the guy
looks down is like i i need to leave my
family and the woman that loves me and
ever my
whole life it's never going to happen
you said let's give them those [ __ ]
supernova i commented on that because
you said there's never been a
a back uh uh bathroom stall blow job
where guys like [ __ ]
i'll put it in a hotel room i'll put it
anywhere i will a road [ __ ] if that
girl
if that girl you suddenly fall in love
with you can't stop texting you can't
stop thinking about
go be with her like good i i it sucks
like i recently had my hopes set to be
like i fell in love with someone who was
not available and
i had hope that they were gonna become
available
put a clear boundary being like i'm done
but if you're ever available let me know
i'm down i'm invested i love you
i would like to try to do this don't
know if i'm going to like you when you
are available
right you can't predict but i would give
it a try
if i was a betting lady i think i'm down
um
and let's take a quick break and tell
you about our next sponsor
stamps.com the summer is showing
welcoming signs of a more
normal life ahead and finally you can
get back to enjoying life's little
pleasures like smiling at your neighbor
seeing a movie and going to the post
office all right some parts of normal
life aren't so great but with stamps.com
you can skip trips to the post office
and save on postage stamps.com brings
the same
us postal and ups shipping services
right to your computer shout out to ups
baltimore hub primary one joe avenue
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship without
needing to take a trip to the post
office you can print you
official us postage and shipping labels
24 7
without having to leave your desk or buy
any fancy equipment
all right all you need is your computer
and standard printer
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it's that
simple stop wasting time going to the
post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with my promo code honeydew
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
there are no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
honeydew that's stamps.com promo code
honeydew
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
our next sponsor is expressvpn watching
netflix without using expressvpn is like
paying for a gym membership but only be
able to use the treadmill you know i'm
saying outside
all right expressvpn lets you change
your online location so you can control
where you want netflix to think
you're located they have almost 100
different server locations so you can
gain access
to thousands of new shows this works
with many other streaming services too
bbc iplayer youtube and more alright you
know i love
expressvpn i don't like traveling around
this country especially
just letting people jump on uh my
internet
so i use expressvpn i was just uh
traveling out of town this weekend i was
watching pulp fiction on canadian
netflix yeah you can get canadian
netflix
you open the app you select the location
you tap one button to connect
and refresh the page to access the
geo-restricted show you watched
why choose expressvpn over other vpns
i'll tell you why it has blazing fast
speeds
you can stream in hd without zero
buffering all right compatible
with all your devices phones laptops
media consoles smart tvs and more
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting your data
so you can browse the web securely so be
smart stop paying
full price for streaming services and
only getting access to a fraction of
their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
honeydew don't forget to use my link at
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew to get an extra
three months
of expressvpn for free and i thought i
had so much hope that it was gonna go
the way i think it's gonna go even
though everything
in my past has led me to believe that it
doesn't ever if things went the way i
thought they
they never go i remember saying to
myself i would do podcasts about it to
myself
or like i would record podcasts to him
because it was someone i
cut off like i don't want to speak to
you until you're available
and so i just like to work through my
feelings of like talking to this person
and not being able to
and just like i would record things and
i remember saying one because i would
listen back because i'm trying to write
songs about it songs like yeah i'm
trying to write like
i want to like taylor swift a little bit
for the to process my feelings about
what's happening you're a multi
you want to do uh direct your own porn
you want to produce your songs you're
crushing it from me like just to process
my emotions because
comedy is just like a kind of easy way
around it for me
like to laugh and be honest about these
things like it's not getting in there
and really like
being like poetic about it like there's
ways to be poetic in comedy but it
always is like
you know like it's vulnerable but it's
not as vulnerable as being like
i love you the first time i met you
like that is so like
when people do that like my panties are
wet we accept
people go like all her eyes on a clear
blue
georgia night with like like
i wish
that's all it's really in my range i'm
taking like i'm working on my voice i'm
writing i'm trying to write songs and
i'm
actually i just play taylor swift songs
i learned the guitar like uh nine months
ago i started playing and it's really
like
been the greatest thing i've ever
brought into my life
since comedy like obsessed saving me
making me
feel great about being single having
time to play it and like
indulge in this new like artistic
obsession it's gonna play with my guitar
my [ __ ] tonight i'm good guys
dude that is it oh my god that's all
i've done i'm
literally ryan it's so funny that that's
literally the two things
i vacillate between when i have down
time i go
should you meditate i'm like again no
i'm gonna bang out some like
you should sing while you play with
yourself oh my god
two in one oh my i could just sit on a
vibrator and play guitar
and test myself do the georgia one again
it was i saw your
eyes on a blue door tonight
i don't know i don't know what it said
[Music]
i just will you be devastated if your
album did better than your [ __ ] stand
though
you wouldn't at all that's all i've ever
wanted this brings us back to jennifer
aniston
i realized i was not going to be
jennifer aniston
because i was not cute enough oh and i
was not a good actress i didn't get the
roles in plays
and i and i wasn't a good enough singer
because i tried to sing i was in
acapella i wouldn't play guitar because
my dad's a really good guitarist and he
is
brutal with his criticism of people that
aren't as good as him as a
whatever at the time 50 year old man so
he was he
i was completely discouraged from
playing guitar even though i have a
natural
like inclination to pick it up i'm like
my dad made me unintentionally made me
feel pretty like
my dad all he wants is for us to play
music with him and my sister and i like
refuse because he's just like
sing with him that too like it's just
like my dad's such a good singer such a
good guitar player that
like he's just too critical but also
this is a devastating moment in my life
and i i'm only just now realizing it
because
um i was in acapella i made it and i was
like an alto i was pretty good i liked
it didn't want to read music
um this is high school and then i
started taking singing lessons like get
better
and my mom told me one day after doing
like six months of singing lessons
that the teacher had called her
privately and told her that
nikki doesn't have it she never will and
that is a waste of your money oh
it's terrible i i mean i'm not joking
you my mom
i think my mom was pleased to bring me
that information
like this is a wrap because she wanted
to go to her garage sales on sunday
morning
i hope she did i hope so much that she
did but my parents early on i used to
sing for them sometimes and they would
go
schoo sing in the bathroom it's better
acoustics and i would know what they
were doing and i'd go sing in that
bathroom and i would
like be crying because i'm like they
just want me to leave the room
so i just got a lot of feedback that i
sucked at rhythm
if you could backdoor your [ __ ] uh
music career
dude i can't like the thing about taylor
swift like i'm never going to be
taylor swift like she's i don't have
time she's had a taylor swift shirt that
that night at super nintendo i have lots
of taylor swift shirts i love her so
much and i realized that
talent like real talent like being
the best at something is obviously a
mixture of like
god-given talent but that's such a small
part of it
and taylor swift has that for music
obviously and songwriting it's just like
something in this deeply empathetic like
very vulnerable art like she's
she's just smart and but she she's just
like
the right things were at play for her to
be what she is i'm so grateful all of
that happened
but i do realize that
you can work hard enough and do the same
things that these people do
if you just put in the hours and like
i'll
so i'm starting right now with guitar
like i'm half and i'm about to get like
bit full in where i like bring someone
to train me on the road and like
really commit some like long hours
because i got to catch up to
like like it's it's going to be
embarrassing if it's shitty like i want
to be good
i care about it like comedy but i'm as
bad as when i started comedy i'm just
older
but if i in when i'm 50 and
13 years i can be [ __ ] great at
songwriting yeah when taylor swift was
13 years into songwriting when she
started when she was 13.
like i'm not talking about age anymore
it's like i have enough life ahead of me
where i could totally
have a career as a a pop artist or a
songwriter at least
anyone outside of eddie murphy ever gone
from comedy to music for real
like stand up not weirdo always being in
the yeah
i don't want to make it comedy songs i
don't think so
i think maybe people have attempted to
like rap childish campino oh yeah yeah
yeah and his shit's so good we allow him
to be multifaceted that's right
i'm just a little like it's just too
vulnerable i can't wait to get to a
place where i'm comfortable
saying on a clear door tonight i can't
wait time
you came to my window everything it's
just like sleeping bags
listening you do sound a lot like i did
it there like
the thing is i can do i can do good
impressions of good singers but i don't
have my voice yet that's the thing it's
like comedy
i don't know i just mimic whoever i hear
on the radio and i do a pretty good job
of it like i can sing
some songs really well but i can't take
what i did in that song
to my own stuff yeah but i'll figure it
out because it takes 10 years
let's go back to our first boyfriend why
did you allow
jeff to be a boyfriend what was it about
this guy where you finally said all
right i'm gonna have a relationship
joke writer on the scene okay very sexy
like just
so funny that just too smart for the
room
brilliant jokes where you're like holy
[ __ ] like like i'm saying like
just there's something special about his
brain and i just loved his jokes
and they seemed like flawless he still
is a guy that i when i do roasts and i
send him what i want for rose jokes like
give him the themes that i'm going for
he's gotten in the most jokes of wow is
that people that i asked you
yeah i treat the rose like it's a
writer's room because it's like the
biggest performance you can have as a
comedian so i
send all my like funniest friends he
doesn't even do comedy anymore i don't
think
maybe he does stand up i hope he does he
nails that oh they're so but he just his
mind is sick
i was just like horny for it and he was
just like aloof and
i think i think i always get the word
aloof wrong but he was just kind of like
didn't
i'd like win him over to be like yeah
but he's also like a dork kind of he was
like an outsider but
awkward just weird social skills
and then uh he really just like he kind
of just like grabbed me one night
and like kissed me and i needed that to
happen i needed
to be like kind of man i hate to say it
like i needed someone to like go in
because
i don't i was so scared to put myself in
those situations and make the first move
i've since changed the way i am
with men this all of this is predicated
by the fact that my first kiss which was
late already
i was 16. okay and um
i wanted to kiss boys so much i was like
obsessed with dave matthews i would just
like
like ju i didn't even know i didn't know
about orgasming i didn't have my first
orgasm until i was
22. and um so i didn't know about that i
didn't masturbate until i was
even beyond that so i wasn't like but i
was horny like so much
didn't know any anything about it or
what to do with it um
but i just wouldn't let myself like be
around boys because my mom kind of
scared me i think my mom gave me a talk
early on like
they're they're like you'll get raped or
like i just sense that
maybe something happened to me when like
i'm reading about people who
have it's been uncovered that they've
been lost but they don't remember it
like it was so young that they don't
make a memory
my stuff kind of fits that so maybe
something it doesn't have to be like a
full-on
baby raping like i a doctor could have a
gross doctor could have slipped a finger
is that right dude child molestation you
have to like
really um open yourself up to the
horrifying truth of it because
child abuse can happen within seconds
like you turn your back and there can be
an image created that
winds up on the dark web that someone
who is with your child naked in a bath
a relative that you trust you go grab a
towel images are created
disgusting images are created within 10
seconds to a baby
and you would never eat no baby yeah i
mean this is sick [ __ ]
and the weirdest part about this this is
a phenomenon i can't i
heard this on sam harris's podcast
child pornography uh it's something like
5 5 of the general population consumes
child pornography
on a regular basis that's a real
statistic
and it's not because all those people
are pedophiles and
are sexually attracted to children all
right this is the interesting part
a lot of those people are end up there
because of porn extremes like which is
i'm on a spectrum of porn extremes
listen i didn't get into porn thinking i
was going to be into women
tied up and like had bags put over their
heads like some weird [ __ ] that you see
and you go why would i ever want that
and then you're watching it in two
months
there's a there's a fine line so these
people that seek out extreme stuff
beheading video like the stuff that
really tests
the [ __ ] up stuff you see um
it ends up in child point that's the
most depraved so these guys end up there
not because they want to [ __ ]
kids which pedophiles do and that's why
they end up there but a lot of those
people now that make up five percent of
the general population
are just like it's one end of the
extreme so that's why you got to be
careful and yeah it's just it's like the
worst stuff and i'm
like it's so funny because i don't have
kids i don't but i've read about
and like i'm not someone to be like i
was probably molested it would make my
life easier if i found out it was
because i would be like okay it's not
me it was that guy
it was that gross doctor it was i
wouldn't even blame my parents i'd be
like they did their best but it was like
it was these guys are slick dude
it's not your fault if you're molested
and like i would
but that's the thing is people go nikki
it's not your fault you're anorexic it
doesn't
it doesn't make it doesn't make me feel
it's like it's not my fault deep down i
feel
i did something i know most people
aren't it's not their fault but i
chose this and the truth is you don't
it's just being unlucky if you get any
of these if these things happen to you
but yeah like i have my first kiss was
assault too
it was [ __ ] terrible i liked this guy
so much
he was like a really close friend he was
so hot he was in the grade above us not
really popular but like
edging like on the edge of popular
definitely one of the hottest guys in
school
like just like bleach blonde surfer dude
tall funny and he he was my friend
and all of my friend like not all my
friends my one friend taylor she really
liked him too and we were both always
just like oh
andy but i wasn't she had hooked up with
guys and
maybe had sex i don't think she had had
sex at this point but she was like going
after him harder than i was i think they
hooked up one night when we were camping
it doesn't matter
we became friends and one night andy and
i were at his place after a football
game we were both on the pep squad and
we'd been flirting all night
it's like f but i had never been kissed
so i told a boy
previously that i liked him and i
thought i was gonna get my first kiss
that night that was in 10th grade
i was in love with this guy who just was
my closest
like outlet to dave matthews because he
could play guitar like dave matthews and
he loved dave matthews as much as me so
it was like
i just loved doug reese we called him we
called him 98 duggars
because that band was hot at the time
that's [ __ ] great so doug reese i was
obsessed it was like my identity in high
school i was like i love dave matthews
everyone knew i loved him
he was my best friend best [ __ ]
nickname dude isn't that great that is
[ __ ] great my friends were funny
that's like my i think that was probably
kirsten yeah same thing with me
growing up all my friends were fine
they're so funny they're still so funny
always it's really i always used to be
so jealous of them because i thought
they were gonna end up on snl and that's
what i secretly wanted and i was just
like god they're just like braver than
me to say things and
eventually i got to like harness of all
their like mannerisms and things that
make me who i am now but
yeah i was in love with doug grace and
one day i was like i need to tell him
like we've been hanging out forever and
it was just like i was pining
and i was like i'm gonna tell him we're
gonna i go over to his house he lives in
my neighborhood
we're in his basement um studying for
chemistry i'm not even focusing and
before this
kirsten my best friend since fourth
grade she had kissed some boys and like
hooked up and probably had oral sex at
this point sophomore
year junior year for sophomore year
and um we were hanging out my house i'm
like going over to dogs i'm gonna tell
him i have to tell him like i can't take
this anymore he's not gonna say anything
and she was i was like but and then
we're gonna kiss like i know he's gonna
be into it and we're gonna kiss
and she i was like but what if i'm bad
like if i'm bad like i don't know and
she was like kiss me i'll i'll tell you
if you're bad and i was like
okay we made out i didn't even realize
that was my first step
i literally didn't realize until like 20
years later i'm not joking you i was on
a podcast and i was like
oh my god that's your first kiss that
was my actual first kiss
i told doug i liked him later that day
he had just gotten a girlfriend from a
private school so i got shut down
i convinced him to break up with her i
pined for him for months when he was
with this girl six months i was like
i love doug and he's with kathryn
throw myself around the hallways
everyone like knew i loved him and he
even like knew like it was just
it was just so i loved him so much and
then one day his best friend
told me in the barnes and barnes noble
parking lot uh
like we would go there at night and like
hang out it was like our central perk
you know
and we were in the parking lot and he
was like doug broke up with the
catherine and i was like
really i started like crying i was like
i remember jumping around
and then we were walking back to the
cafe to keep reading magazines we didn't
buy and uh
you know buying chai lattes on our
parents credit cards and
as i'm walking back i realized i
do not like this guy anymore something
just happened
on the walk it just clicked he was like
he's he's on his way up here and i was
like
no i don't like him anymore what the
[ __ ] there's exactly where your [ __ ]
unavailability is born oh my god you
liked him when he was unavailable yeah
and that scared me that
and then as soon as he was it's scary
and then throughout my life
i have said it become uh attracted to
men and then something happens and i
become
like like repulsed like the
it's flipped so and it's the worst
feeling because sometimes
you are in a sexual relationship with
this person and you're going through the
motions and you're having sex with
someone you like
like are repulsed by and you don't know
why like something they did it's like
you just feel like
icky and i've had to stop in the middle
of sex and be like i
this is so harsh to say tell me you said
this is something you've actually said
well i did this to a guy one time i was
a little too high to be having sex and i
and i already was like not
really i was looking at him as more of a
friend and it just felt like [ __ ] a
friend it just felt icky like it just
felt
no i don't he loves me too much it was
like huh
and i was like i i have to stop you have
to get out of me like you got to get out
of me
and he was like wait what and like
that's how i said it did you really yeah
i mean that's the softer thing of what i
really want to say which like if i let
this continue and
i have already for like 30 seconds after
i didn't want it i'm at this point i'm
raping myself with you
i'm using you to rape myself like that
it was me betraying myself
and i couldn't do it so i don't let
myself do that anymore
listen please if you don't that has to
go into your
really raping myself with it's a little
harsh but yes it's
true that's two rape jokes you could get
away with oh man yeah the first one on
the tonight show by the way
was i um you know i'm 21 whatever
in college i like dated a lot of frat
guys my friends were like don't date
them they're douche bags and i was like
they're not that bad the guy i actually
dated he was like so sweet because he
waited to like
the third date before he leaned in to
rape me and so that was that's and you
got
that tonight but it's all true like the
guy that i ended up kissing like
he was my friend after the football game
we're at his place mitch hedberg was on
letterman that night the first time i
saw mitch hedberg we were watching and
we were like oh my god so funny
we're hanging out his parents living
room which we had done a lot
at that point and at one point he just
goes um
i like you and i was like um uh
what like it was called me by surprise
like i didn't see this coming i was like
really
i was like okay well i like you too and
he was just like okay all right well
and it was kind of like awkward and he's
like so i can like ask you out sometime
and i was like yeah
yes like i was like oh my god and then
he
leapt from the couch from his like the
barco lounger
to the couch i was on and like just made
out with me like fast that was my first
kiss from a guy and it was just like
i was like no no like what are you doing
like no and like pushed him off and he
was so embarrassed that that had been my
response that he like
went ran into the kitchen was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like was like slamming cabinets
i did he was making a lot of commotion
in the kitchen
being like such a [ __ ] and i was like
andy
calm down it's not that big of a deal
like i was just like sorry i was like
got scared i was like trying to like
make it
better and that wasn't the bad part was
him telling him to get off like he got
off me that was fine that happens
like it was a little too aggressive but
it's a young guy
the reaction afterwards though he
apparently was chugging
like whatever he could find liquor he
could find and then eventually i was
like
will you drive me home like i don't know
where you're what you're doing but this
is weird i need to go home
and um he told me how he was going like
75 like in a 30 like
just being so dangerous like in a
dangerous car
just like and i didn't always drunk but
just being like
really like so scary in the way home and
then when i got out
at my house he took off before my other
foot was like out the door and i like
almost fell down
and the door like closed on my like hit
my leg and i just go
[ __ ] you and i'd never have that cut
like ever
and i screamed that in the night like
that's how i was not like that type of
girl and i was just like
the next day i had to be on a float with
him all day at this green tree festival
and it was like
he wouldn't talk to me so it just i am
always scared of
of make love a god of being a tease and
having a guy be like
[ __ ] you like you do like i've had an
ex-boyfriend go
you do this to guys nikki you get them
to love you and then you throat like
then you
change your mind it's like i didn't
choose to not be attracted to you
anymore
i quit drinking and i saw you clearly
for who you are
and i still [ __ ] you when i'm sober
because i already have [ __ ] you and it
doesn't
it's not as scary to me because new dick
is scary and yours i've already seen
that's why i want to sleep with you
again not because i want to cause you
pain
i only want to cause pain to men who
have like hurt me and actually i don't
even want to do that anymore
i really don't have this like vendetta
like i used to
like i just got like my heart kind of
crushed and
i said literally this morning yeah like
i got word that a thing i had hoped for
is like a lot of hope for is dead in the
water
and i'm fi i was like i literally got
the text and i go
thank you like what a gift to keep this
person out of my life
to put to [ __ ] this flame
right now is gonna make me so open to so
many other things because i was holding
out hope for that
so i'm glad it went away but generally
when i get rejected or
and i haven't been communicated with
well and not really respected
like this situation um i
tend to get like vindictive and i just
don't want to do that this time because
i
unders like i
i try to see now like how in pain people
are and how their choices are not
truly not about me like i can get there
and be like this isn't because i'm not
lovable
or i wasn't good enough to have this
person
make change changes in their life that
would accommodate my
like it's it's not i don't need to make
it that and i haven't
and the biggest part of not making it
that the key
to getting over a guy who you're in love
with who
uh you are like have told you want to
spend your life with or at least give it
a chance i was like
let's get married for two years i'll be
out before i'm 40. i'll be like still
hot
i will have done it i'll know what not
to do two years i literally i will not
feel like that i feel like that's a
success i don't think marriage has to
last forever like yes we hope it does
but it doesn't mean it's a failure if it
fails two years though is not i agree
with that these people are like we've
been married 15 years i'm like that's
[ __ ] that's a long time that's a
successful way
that means that was successful for six
of those years but like
let's wrap this up i know there's kids
and money and situations
and emotional abuse i get it um i'm
lucky that i have not entered into
a marriage with someone at this point
with what i know and i'm i'm grateful
but i would do it and i would protect
myself in it
going into it but i'm so down to like
fall madly in love and
have it just like burn out that's what
this felt so good because i never
here's the key i never had sex with this
person
oh okay i fell in love no sex i did not
give myself fully to him because he
wasn't mine at
like when i i was still well he wasn't
able to be fully invested in me
so he didn't get to have sex with me
very very hard to do
to not have sex with someone that you
are dying to have sex with and
you know like but that based on the
research i've
gone through like biologically you get
like addicted to someone when their dick
is in you
and you shouldn't let it in anyway but
listen there's only so
many ways to get a guy off and if you're
taking penis and vagina off the table
you got to put it in other ways
if you're hooking up so i i i was hurt
when i it fell through but because i
didn't have that chemical attachment
that happens when you like have a penis
in you
and the thing that i'm saving for love
when that goes away
it's devastating but i didn't get that
so i'm like
the withdrawal i was like quitting
smoking it was like the the effects of
like i
long for his smell wore off after like
seven days
i stole a pillow case from his hotel
room and
i smelled it to re-up the love i'd be
like
like remember that you love this person
because hold on they might come through
and then i was starting to smell kind of
like i don't really like this and then
some days i would be like ovulating so
it was like
but i'm gonna throw it out when i get
home i'm over it will i
we don't know stay tuned for the next
my next appearance on the honeydew i had
to look at the sign to make sure it was
the honeydew
it is you got it we never got to the
store you wanted to talk about with your
friend
no we got to so much good stuff yeah
i'll come back for that i'm saying come
back for that yeah
um okay so now i'm going to ask you what
i ask everybody their first time after
everything we've talked about what you
know and especially that
that age the pivotal age of 16 what
advice would you give to your 16 year
old self
um
god now i like honestly my initial one
before we started because you told me
this was
um there's gonna be a girl named taylor
swift someday
that just wait for her and like as soon
as she comes out
like seek out female songwriters
who there's someone out there that's
speaking your pain and your truth like
look for them look beyond the beatles
and dave matthews
and like go deep with music and help you
through this right now
in a way that you don't even know
because taylor swift isn't born yet
there's some others that will do in the
media and nikki
you're meant to be a songwriter you
really are and
you need to do everything you can to do
it and if that means becoming a famous
comedian
that can pay for people to
like pay for people to pay attention to
you and like
uh be nice to you when you suck at
guitar like if that's the
environment you have to make for
yourself to like pursue a pop star
career or whatever you want like a
songwriting career
um do it because that's really the dream
like i wanna i love being able to
communicate via podcast like i would
never give this up
i might give it up to actually be a
singer oh yeah you'd have to try you
could just help so many people
with your like music just heals in a way
that comedy sometimes does
it just doesn't no way comedy is so
challenging you have to like
write all the time and it's so great
because you can process stuff in real
time but
real time with bill maher this friday oh
wait no i was over here feeling
those dead see your on the georgia blue
sky i was feeling it
listen i've got some i got some things
to say inside me and i i've got poet
poetry in my soul and i might re might
release stuff under a pseudonym
but i would tell also uh
nikki to to look into meditation to 16
year old
nikki like investigate meditation
and consciousness and sam harris because
when you discover that and your dad's
not right about everything
i know you think he is but he's not he's
got some things wrong
and that's not because he's not an
intelligent awesome person but he's
they're very your parents are wrong on a
lot of stuff and you'll and that's so
that doesn't make
them bad people which it'll take out
longer to learn that too
um thank you for coming on here and
thank you for being [ __ ] awesome
i wish i could hang out with you all day
you're the best you are too please plug
everything you'd like to plug to your
nikki blazer podcast please just
subscribe you guys i'm not
uh it's pretty much like this if you if
you enjoyed this you'll like it the
nicky glazer podcast with andrew collin
who you
will hear on this podcast as well so
soon he's so funny
um he's my roommate and my podcast
co-host uh we
film it where we do the podcast from
spare bedroom in our apartment in st
louis
um and then fuckboy island f boy island
sorry
on hbo tune into that if you like
reality tv
and you enjoy dating shows this one's
wild it's a show with
i forget what like i can say about
contractually i think it's like a lot of
men that are either a [ __ ] boy or or an
f boy sorry or a nice guy and then these
girls that are looking for love have to
like figure out if
who is who and listen i learned a lot on
this show
did you yeah i learned a lot about
myself and i learned a lot about men and
i learned a lot about
reality tv and it's awesome that was the
best thing i ever did
was that show the most fun i've ever had
watch me have the best time of my life
if you want to watch someone having a
good time while they're
making tv which is rare to find on tv by
the way
you know like it's people are mostly
just like sometimes phoning it in but
they're good at it like i was actually
having a genuine
amazing time all right i'm gonna watch
it so fun and weird
yeah f-boy island thank you and my tour
see you out there again go see nicki
live
as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all
next week
[Music]
you